the best thing that has happened i mean
there's a lot of bittersweet
you know uh this year the death of
george floyd
the uh coveted 19 um
the ex a lot of white supremacy things
going on
uh but you know what this is the best
thing that has happened because now
we're having to confront this it should
have been confronted
decades ago you're saying it's good that
this stuff is happening
yes yeah because people are are now
addressing it you know rather than
shoving it under the carpet and lying in
the closet
right you know because in the past it
was always taboo
to talk about these kinds of things
people didn't want to talk about racism
and
supremacy and all that kind of stuff and
now
we're having to confront it because it's
in our face
and i'm going to tell you what's
happening that that the media
knows but they don't talk about
this country was built on a two-tier
society
white supremacy and slavery
and over the years we progressed like
this
maybe like this but never like this
not on equal basis all right
when i was a child um the black
population in this country
was twelve percent native americans were
only one percent
a hispanic people latino people around
two percent
asians around four percent uh white
people like 84 86 percent so
the racist people their biggest nemesis
were black people
at 12 that's way too much you know they
didn't care about
one percent native american the uh the
attitude was oh just take them put them
on a reservation forget about them
they didn't care about two percent uh
hispanic or latino
but twelve percent oh no no we can't
have that all right
so today black people remain at 12
we're like 12.9 or something now we
really haven't grown
um so we're almost at 13
hispanic people have grown to like 17
point something percent
so and asians i believe they've grown to
like six percent
if you take just black people at 12
percent in this country
and 17 latino hispanic that right there
is 29
non-white this is happening
okay and if you want to to prove it to
yourself
google the census u.s census bureau the
census is taken every 10 years
all right look watch the census
every 10 years from 1960 black people
have remained at 12 percent
other things that like hispanics you
know have grown
and the white population is coming down
it is well predicted
that in the year 2042 that's going to be
a shift
for the first time in the history of the
united states
it will be 50 50. 50 white
50 non-white for the that includes
black latino hispanic you know asian
whatever native american et cetera all
right between 2045
and 2050 it's going to shift
whites will become the minority in this
country now
yep and um
there are plenty of white people in this
country plenty of white people in this
country
who embrace that they say hey i'm cool
with that you know
evolution is what happens no big deal
there's another percentage that are not
happy with that
those are your white supremacists all
right which includes the kkk the
neo-nazis the alt-right
whatever else um and individuals
when you have sat on the power and sat
on the throne
of power for 401 years
you don't want to get off i have been
here for 401 years
as a descendant of slaves the first
slaves came here
in 1619 that's 401 years ago
and i'm i'm a descendant of slaves okay
and when you've held that kind of power
for
for that long over somebody like me
you don't want to give it up look at our
current presidency
he has power he doesn't want to give it
up right right you know when you have
power you don't want to give it up
so they're seeing their thrown legs
being whittled down
and now their butts are coming down to
the level of the inferior people
you know they don't want that uh
i said i'm a musician just like you know
if i had a hit record
you know number one on the charts i
don't want to get off at number one i
don't want to fall down the number 10
number 99 now i'm off the top 100. yeah
yeah you won't stay at the top
right okay so this is why you're seeing
all these groups popping up trying to
recruit come join us
you know we're going to take our country
back we're going to make america great
again
you know we're going to build that wall
send those people back to wherever they
came from
and so on and so on all right that's
because do you know what uh what white
flight is
white flight yeah no never heard of it
you really
never how old are you i'm 33. okay
that's why
okay okay
white flight was very big back in the
70s 80s 90s but now
there is no more white flight white
flight you ever heard of white flight
okay how old are you i'm 23. oh that
definitely explains
it okay
you have a neighborhood that's all white
and um eventually
people who were not white began moving
into the neighborhood
okay and then the white people they move
out and they go to somewhere else where
it's all white
okay and then the gradually that becomes
integrated and they fly again
they keep flying to they they want to
they want an all-white neighborhood
right that's called white flight okay
okay
there is no more white flight because
they can't fly anywhere nowhere to go
nowhere to go now
exactly exactly everywhere you go
there's somebody who does not look like
you
right right okay so white flight is over
uh you want to leave the planet
exact precisely then you've got great
you know white people only on them yeah
um elon musk is going to make that
happen oh the funniest thing i ever saw
when went to this uh clan rally public
place was uh
uh in front of the governor's mansion in
maryland um
all these white uh you know white
supremacists and clan robes and stuff
they kept you having white power
white power uh and these these these uh
three or four college kids showed up
with their bodies painted green
and every time the clan would yell while
power power they go green power
green power i got a picture of them in
my book that is
but anyway um
so this is why all these groups are
trying to recruit
because the landscape is changing right
it used to be mostly white landscape now
you're seeing people from all over
you know you you call miami little
havana
right you know and and you know a little
chinatown and little you know
you know hispanic town and you know
someone and so on you know or
a little or little ethiopia or whatever
different places right
uh those names didn't exist you know 20
30 years ago
right so people are freak some people
are freaking out about that so they go
and join these groups
that promise to take the country back
all right
and when that doesn't happen they get
frustrated
they say you know what if the clan can't
do it
or or the uh or the nazis can't do it
i'll do it myself
and they go out on their own and walk
into a black church boom
or into a synagogue or the well or the
walmart in el paso
right these are these are lone wolves
now
we have intelligence agencies fbi that
kind of thing right
who have operatives that can that can
blend in
they can go and join these groups you
know they have the look and they
they talk the talk and they go and
undercover and they become one of those
people
and they gather intelligence and report
it back and we foil those plots
like we had we had intelligence
operatives in in the in
in this group that was going to kidnap
the governor right that's how they got
busted
but you cannot infiltrate a lone wolf
it's only one person
you follow what i'm saying yeah yeah you
infiltrate a group you can't fight a
lone wolf
as we get closer and closer to 2042
unfortunately we're going to see more
and more lone wolves
because they feel their country is being
taken over and they feel it's their
patriotic duty
this is a white homeland this country
was was built by white men and
the constitution was signed by white men
you know they forget the fact that
it was built off the backs of slaves
just it's all white you know
in their minds that's right so they're
going to take it upon themselves
to to defend this country you know that
that's that's that's
what they're doing in fact you saw a
lone wolf a couple weeks ago
um that 17 year old boy who came from
illinois into wisconsin right
kyle rittenhouse right right he shot
three people killed two of them
blew off the third guy's arm and then
went home yeah
with his gun that's a lone wolf
okay you're gonna see more and more of
those people as we get closer and closer
to 2042
they are becoming unhinged um okay so
you said you're 33.
yeah so do you remember 1999 pretty well
no no not really i wasn't doing i wasn't
paying attention to anything except for
surf surfing and skate skating around
town and just being an idiot
well in 1999 people were really
uh having high anxiety because
the year 2000 was coming oh yes i
remember that it was called y2k
yep i thought the world was going to end
the world was going to end my vcr won't
work anymore
is there something new the mayan
calendar ended yeah yeah exactly
yeah people were like freaking out man
they're taking all their money out of
banks and
hiding it in their mattress because they
figured their banking system was going
to shut down
you know the calendar was going to go
crazy yeah electronics weren't going to
work on work anymore
the coffee maker wasn't going to work
because he had to program it differently
um so they were on high angst
what what the year 2000 y2k
was to all of us or whatever 2042
is the white supremacist y2k really yeah
and 2042 is only 22 years from now
so do you think the farther we go like
the
the closer we get to 2042 the more
radicalized people are going to get yep
on that side and the moment
like that we're going to see yep unless
we start addressing it now
we have been we have been reactive for
so
long we need to be proactive
we need to be more proactive this
country is changing
and it's going to continue to change you
can't stop evolution
all right but you but you can teach
people how to deal with it
how to get over their anxiety how to
accept it it's going to be okay
you know so what if you know if you know
you open your front door
and this neighbor looks different and
that neighbor looks different and that
one looks different
no big deal earlier you you mentioned
that you think
it's somewhat a good thing what's been
happening
yeah around the count in this country in
the last year
let me explain that to you let me i want
to finish this thought
um what i what i think you're trying to
say
is by the fact that these things are
happening and they're being exposed
they're coming out from under the rug
we we're realizing that they do exist
we're realizing that there are weeds in
the garden that have to be pulled
we've always realized that but we've
never wanted to deal with it
we not not black people white people
you know they they don't want to address
it do you do you think that
donald trump becoming president is also
somewhat a good thing in that respect
that he
has kind of sparked
kind of an uprising because like donald
trump there's all
would you say that all kkk members are
would be trump supporters yes they are
right
yeah so i what i say is
um not every trump supporter is a racist
i have a lot of friends who are trump
supporters
right who are not racist at all me too
yeah
okay so not all trump supporters are
racists but every racist is a trump
supporter
right so there's a difference and here's
the thing um
i would say that donald trump is the
worst president we've ever had
but he is the best thing that's happened
to this country
that's the bittersweet part of it um
as a result of donald trump you know uh
we now have the metoo movement
which is good for women you know we
didn't have me to move
before him and he sort of activated all
that
with all his uh misogyny and all that we
have a lot more conversations about race
that we were not having before that we
should have had a long time ago
donald trump did not invent racism by
any means no
neither did obama or george bush or bill
clinton or any of any of those people
it's been around for a long time but we
as a nation have failed to address it
properly
and now we're having to because because
we failed and now we're having to
address it
violently even like with charlottesville
or now you're having all these groups
with these um armed militias and all
this kind of stuff
you know getting ready to confront each
other in the streets they're all
concerned about that 2042
you know and um this is why i said we
have to be proactive
and not reactive yeah